over time Matt Welch you grew up with a
chimp I did not grow up with Jim but I
know someone who whose father was a ride
taught to slang language I must be had
in competition and that's not nice to
talk about my brother's not like all
right
hey I'm repaired my relationship with my
cousins tonight congressman Adam Schiff
do you trust your Republican
congressional counterparts to impartial
II investigate the Trump administration
to impartially investigate yes do you
trust your Republican counterparts great
question I think they're serious about
it I really in particular we have a new
Republican lead Mike Conaway from Texas
who is determined to work in a
non-partisan way so I'm optimistic yeah
I am you know I can only say you don't
seem that way
on TV they don't seem their talking
points seem to be more of what we were
talking about they're like nothing to
see here and you know everybody
investigates everybody and the
president's under attack let him do his
job
so you think behind closed doors you
hear something different yes in my
conversations with my new Republican
lead he assures me he is determined to
follow the facts wherever they lead he
wants this done in a strictly non
partisan fashion and I think he has
helped us get back on track after we had
the whole blow-up over Devin Nunez in
the White House so I'm optimistic but I
have to be or it's hard to get up in the
morning right and we press forward and
and if I get to the point where I feel
at any time we can't do the job we need
to do then I'll be very public about it
okay
well I hope that's true because you know
sometimes they say those things and then
they get a phone call from Steve Bannon
or somebody and next thing you know the
story line has changed I mean I saw that
this week senator Burke sounded pretty
good the first day and then the second
day he was like well I'm certainly not
asking for a special prosecutor this is
not where the rubber meets the road
special prosecutor whether you you the
walk data you don't there are now a few
Republicans who are coming out in
support of a special prosecutor that has
been some real and significant movement
how are they McCain
no one there actually Kaufman I think
from Colorado Republican senator there
are some House members that have come
out in favor of an independent
commission
that's fairly new all of this is
movement and I think this firing of
Comey and all the aftermath if there was
any lack of diligence or seriousness
about the investigation in the Bureau
before it and I'm not saying there was I
think they are doubly determined that
they're going to follow this trail
they're going to do their jobs because
they know we're going to be watching
very carefully to make sure there's no
interference with their work okay
Dresden Amash and Walter Jones two
Republicans in the house we're both
pretty strong libertarian leaders
they've signed up for that independent
committee so how many do we need to be a
tipping point I think the number last I
saw was 201 199 Democrats and two
Republicans so you need the bigger
tipping point when they come if the
president's approval drops below a
certain point because right where my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle in the house at large are going to
find their voice is when they feel this
president is dragging them down and it's
no longer going to be politically
palatable for them to have anything to
do with him okay does Sean Spicer
or any spokesman for the Trump
administration have any credibility left
Crowder's are saying once you talk from
the bushes it's over that is it that the
line that is you've gotten to the end
once your you want to come to work after
that I mean deep throat was in the
parking garage that was that was fairly
I can't imagine if you're a spokesman
for this White House having to go out
there every day and just like either
tell these lies they protect these lines
I mean you can't succeed at your job I
would rather clean Fukushima with my
tongue you know the the my my favorite
comment of the week was by Sarah
Huckabee Sanders who in trying to
justify the firing of James Comey said
that he was guilty of atrocity atrocity
so he is now Bashar al-assad apparently
he must have gas people in the bureau
but to be compared that's the trump
administration definition of atrocities
truth-telling fact-finding you know
atrocities could I ask a question
from the pessimistic proletariat I tell
my friends all the time I was like I
don't know if anything will come of the
investigations not that there isn't
anything to be found or any retribution
that happened should something be found
ever since I was a kid we projected
ourselves as the absolute leader of the
free world we projected out there as the
strongest country like it was hard for
me to accept Russia had anything to do
with our election based on the fact I as
I witnessed Reagan taken out Gorbachev
WWE style and I saw rocky beat the [ __ ]
out of the Russian so forth court in my
mind after Red October we had won that
and we had moved on and then we just
have to worry about [ __ ] terrorists
so much my question really is you know
to the good men at the table
and lately there's this country can
afford to be perceived as having been
gotten or having been weak enough and if
we if we are willing to do that I think
we can change but if we're not I think
that more people are involved in the
protecting of the person that we have as
president than just the Republicans who
are quiet about it I think we're all a
little too quiet about it you know I
think again there should be across the
aisles there should be outraged and the
fact that there's not shows me that
people are doing exactly what you just
said protecting their political on
equity until it pits until he drifts
below a certain point and then they can
come out of the [ __ ] bushes and say I
was never with her anyway thank you for
that excellent
regular man streak version of American
history after the collision after the
Cold War you got to the truth
all right animal do you think is Lanka
is an effective advocate for women in
the trump administration is it fair to
ask her to be one no no this is where
we're putting too much putting too much
on her if she had any integrity she
wouldn't have accepted an office in the
White House we don't do that in this
country that's Banana Republic yes this
is we don't we don't do this we separate
families another family story we
separate our family from our government
well we don't always Bobby Kennedy was
the Attorney General so we don't always
well good it was you liked him I liked
him too but I'm just saying I don't
worry about Adam I do not even go like
to history I mean here is a woman who
doesn't have any policy experience this
is not her area for you months earlier I
just want to be a daughter I'm not going
to do it even they're all such liars if
it strikes me as in in a lot of
countries where there's a monarchy where
a graft goes through the princelings
sure all the graph goes to the children
of the king and here you want cos bran
gets these trademarks they've always
wanted
does anyone imagine for a millisecond
that if Trump hadn't decided to reject
his early impulse and adhere to the one
China policy that the Ivanka Trump brand
would have ever gotten those trademarks
not in a million years and here's the
real risk that that we become just like
these other countries where the graft
goes through the kids yeah are we an
oligarchy well yeah yeah kind of yes I
mean if you if you define oligarchy as
the the opinions of the people because
they've studied this don't really have a
lot of say in what gets enacted they've
gone down the list of the issues you
know the people want to raise in the
minimum wage they want like 10 different
things and it's just not even on the
agenda because that's what an oligarchy
is justice but this is a little
different you're saying this is a
step beyond oligarchy this is this is
that kind of corrupt stuff where I mean
we've seen it with so many of the
dictators that we used to play footsie
with Saddam Hussein yeah
the two kids you know today Inc you say
Oh day in [ __ ] but I would inject a
note of both humility and like let's not
tear down all of our civic institutions
in the name of opposing someone that we
disagree with here because you're going
to need those civic institutions
institutions what I was saying is that
when you when you say that we live in an
old again something that can be compared
to Saddam Hussein's Iraq or whatever you
deceive simply I mean everybody's has
their Facebook you know page feeding
constantly those like Keith Olbermann
resistance you know coming down from the
hills if you tear down the institutions
and say that we are totally robbed we
want to restore them I know them yeah I
know what I'm saying not us who are
tearing them down I'm saying that have
some faith in checks and balances insist
the people you want them have some faith
in the airy and supply case but it does
not keep a list I've been saying up
since last October it looks like a
slow-moving coup to me so face yes cool
exciting when you say that now i time to
outrage why you're saying that because
what i feel is that was a metaphor high
cement hot flash in his head is that
what what's happening right now when the
whole election of donald trump was a
rebuke against the idea that serving
your country that government is actually
the in public service is a value i mean
and to me that's what staring down the
we should be marching in the streets 24
hours a day except with menopause i
couldn't do it on have the energy but no
the thing is is if this is i mean i mean
really do you think that public service
is not a value that's what motivated
because it is i want to add because
every single day the government right
now is we're just we're just reacting to
these seems like it was reacting to
tweets reacting to every crazy thing
that's been happening in the Trump
administration and they can't do their
job there are all these unfilled
positions as if as if there isn't a
you to the work that's being done by
people in the Energy Department people
in the EPA people don't know what to do
I understand not being replaced a real
challenge that we're facing right now is
we've had a dysfunctional Congress for a
long time we now have a dysfunctional
presidency along with it
and if you look at the issues we're
talking about in terms of potential
corruption or kleptocracy within a
normal Congress and a functional
Congress we would have a Government
Reform Committee looking into the
emoluments issue for example is a
violation of the Constitution going on
right now because the Trump family is
advertising in China that you can get
you know in good with the administration
if you do business or with us with us we
should have a gun reform committee
investigating that issue we should have
a Justice Department investigating that
issue maybe they decide no it's
completely copacetic
but they ought to be looking into it and
they're not instead we have there's
private litigants they were doing their
scandals that's the that's the thing
with this man it's like always being in
this swarm of bees but that committee
cannot get that committee to do how do
you get things done every day it seems
like there's something new well you know
what what you're doing here actually is
very powerful
exactly you put it like bargaining here
is very powerful job may I find my book
for you
Penza man all right thank you very much
ladies gentlemen please buy my book the
artist Emil a thousand one from fat joke
[Applause]